sie wollen auf und davon
familie tobler aus dem thurgau sucht das
große abenteuer in australien lanier und
hansjörg eger aus dem aargau bauen in
thailand eine seniorenresidenz familie
tänzer aus dem kanton bern träumt von
einem besseren leben und wagte neuanfang
in florida wiedersehen mit hermann
schönbächler
der bieler förster und seine familie
haben das glück tief im kanadischen wald
gefunden
[Musik]
eigentlich sollten jetzt die ersten
mieter durch die seniorenresidenz von
lanier und hansjörg eger schlendern hier
im restaurant würden sie sich mit einem
drink von der brütenden sonne thailands
erholen
doch die baustelle steht still hans jörg
jäger muss die rentner vertrösten
letzte woche war bereits die erste
mieterin in thailand angekommen ihren
bungalow konnte sie lediglich im rohbau
besichtigen
nach tagen im engen zählt überraschte
rolf dobler seine familie mit ihrem
ersten haus in der neuen heimat
australien
[Musik]
die kurkarte in kanada machten für
einmal nicht die maschinen den größten
lärm und familie den server suchte in
ihrer neuen heimat florida fuß zu fassen
[Musik]
denzer könnte sich einen
hochdruckreiniger
[Musik]
in thailand hat es seit jahren nicht
mehr so viel geregnet
wenn hansjörg eger an seine
seniorenresidenz denkt steht ihm das
wasser bis zum hals
frank fischer weiß der hört nicht
punkten
die dna mit freude auf
hansjörg jägers erste mieterin die
basler rang charlie becker war vor einer
woche in thailand angekommen weil ihr
bungalow in der seniorenresidenz noch
nicht fertig ist muss sie im hotel
wohnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
rolf dobler ist bodenleger und will in
zukunft spezielle bodenbeläge nach
australien importieren
bevor der ernst des lebens beginnt geht
er mit seiner familie auf eine
dreimonatige reise durch die neue heimat
[Musik]
elisabeth euro was man nicht
vorhergesehen dass winter ist eigentlich
darum ihr gern hätte man sich sparen
macht das ganze leben hat nichts gefühlt
achtung
die thurgauer familie hat genügend
ersparnisse um das leben in australien
locker anzugehen hoppers einzige pflicht
gutes brennholz finden also jetzt im
reise ist eigentlich aber sexy das muss
nach können uns für überhaupt noch
wieder warm halten
wir haben wirklich halten und ohne
leistung mit dem baby aber ich glaube
sie spielen sie machen menschen probleme
und ich glücklich bin mir mit nach sind
ihren zeltanhänger haben die tobias
13.000 kilometer durch australien
gezogen
[Musik]
viel mühsamer läuft der start ins neue
leben in florida bei familie denzer sie
wohnt zwar in ihrem traumhaus doch es
ist nicht eingerichtet die töchter
larissa und franke haben noch keine
betten
ja ich tue ich es doch richtig macht
doch nichts
[Musik]
es war natürlich ein segen lauf des
jahres
dennis tänzer liebte ihren eingespielten
haushalt in der schweiz das chaos in
neuenhaus stört sie
ganz anders ihr mann kleid er genießt
seinen amerikanischen traum in vollen
zügen
[Musik]
air china in der lage sind babys
langweiliges leben wird christine und
hermann schönbächler leben mit ihren
kindern seit zwei jahren in kanada
in ihrem paradies hier gibt es keine
sündigen äpfel sondern reife waldbeeren
setzte sie die beschlüsse der
agrarpolitiker herrschte
stina richtig auf überhaupt aber so wie
[Musik]
in der schweiz um mitternacht elfmal
gegen die 24 stunden erreichbar fixies
sind vielleicht die sache ist auch
entspannt kann man sie intensität und
wann ziehen aber es ist ganz gut und
selten sich ab und zu nach deutschland
mit 24 deiner kinder ihrem alter ist
jürgen boos und dass ich das lässt
[Musik]
mit dem zug bleibt ein geldstück in den
händen bruders liegen geht ein wunsch in
erfüllung
dass man gute geist hand geplant und das
konzept auf gold in diesem moment nur
dass wunsch natürlich auch gesundheit
liebe und power
[Musik]
juni
weil auf ihrer baustelle wegen des
regens nichts läuft besichtigen lange
und hansjörg eger den berühmten bruder
von kurier an den ausflug machen sie
aber nicht zum eigenen vergnügen
sie wollen den mietern ihrer
seniorenresidenz auch ein attraktives
freizeitprogramm bieten können die
zimmer dennoch mit der beute der heißt
mir sind drei dass man keinen offenen um
die spiele ja der sara foster
internetseite dass man uns verrückt
machen und da haben jetzt ja immer noch
wie weggeschoben und nach einer hammer
lied müssen
der schnitt ist ein coburger hat er
nicht einfach mal wieder tagen weg aber
das ist im moment machen und tina
schütze der lage machen dass man einfach
moderner verfahren können wir überhaupt
gewonnen
[Musik]
auch in florida geht alles langsamer als
dennis tänzer lieb ist
[Musik]
die familie wohnt in einem provisorium
die töchter larissa und franca warten
noch immer auf ein richtiges bett ihre
mutter fühlt sich in so einem haushalt
gar nicht wo man hingehört in einem haus
das morgen ersten also bis jetzt ohne
therapie möglich freuen
das schöne ist dass sich alle wohlfühlen
also das ist meine kollegen hoffen dass
das nicht stimmt ach ja und sie das
wirklich
ja
was will man sich wie sich bedenkt dass
weder als machen wir daraus
so
[Musik]
heraus
die bündnerin ist zwar ausgewandert in
florida angekommen ist sie noch nicht
[Musik]
denise tänzer war zufrieden mit ihrem
leben in der schweiz sie wanderte nur
ihrem mann zuliebe aus
clyde dancer blüht in florida auf mit
dem hochdruckreiniger bewaffnet holte
aus zum großen befreiungsschlag vom
alltagstrott in der schweiz sein job als
geschäftsführer einer garage hatte ihn
immer mehr frustriert
ich habe mich auf das gefreut diese
gesellschaften schluss gemacht ist zu
gast im schwester was machen
[Musik]
die ganze zu reden
gehlen und kevin tobler werden in zwei
wochen eingeschult
dann sind so lange ferien nicht mehr
möglich die boden haben während der
reise gelernt was die schule nicht
bieten kann
sie haben ihre neue heimat kennen
gelernt dass mir auch heute wo das mir
sind dann habe ich immer gesagt
schweizer und eigentlich gar nicht
getraut zum zeigt mir wo jetzt denn er
steht zum schluss wo wir so richtig
klappen eigentlich ein klimatisierter
webseite wo sind die hat er auch vor der
schweiz aber wir wollten und brütet in
johannesburg
naja und ist schon immer als tourist
aber hart getroffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der schwere sturm der vor einem jahr
große teile des waldes zerstört hatte
hält förster hermann schönbächler noch
immer auf trab
[Applaus]
die arbeit mit dem sogenannten scatter
erfordert viel erfahrung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
potsdam potsdam erzielten kristallisiert
das ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hermann schönbächler chef hält große
stücke auf den schweizer und überlässt
dem die verantwortungsvollsten aufgaben
während ihr mann im wald arbeitet
besucht christine schönwälder ihre beste
freundin cora lee sie wohnte im nahen
städtchen terry
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin so glücklich
ich liebe christine auf unsere männer
sind dicke freunde
sie gehen zusammen auf die jagd
christine und ich waren uns auf anhieb
sympathisch und ja ich mag ihre kinder
[Musik]
in thailand kann endlich wieder
gearbeitet werden
der regen hat nachgelassen
[Musik]
bald sollten die ersten der 13 bungalows
bezugsbereit sein
nanni und hans jäger werden sie für 1000
franken im monat vermieten
der aargauer ist unter druck
kaum ist der erste bungalow endlich
fertiggestellt muss ihn hans jörg jäger
bereits wieder umbauen
die türen vom gang zum wc will audi hat
mit dem man daraus am markt und da hatte
befunden dass er nicht gut dass zwei
türen also in rottenburg zeichneten sie
einmal auf das siebter
wenn aber entschied dass man sie vor der
stube heiligenbilder getöse
rollstuhlgängig machen das mit dem
rollstuhl ina hund und es braucht man
sich auch gleich auf die sietas-werft
ein rollstuhl land machen redakteuren
ich glaube dass ich das team und da muss
ich rücksicht auf lange und wir sind
trotz thailand und der glaube es ist
wenn sie sind das bringt im rücken haben
denn er muss die neue tür wieder
abmontieren um den eingang auf die
andere seite des badezimmers zu
versetzen
[Applaus]
und drittens aussicht gestellt aber wenn
ich da meine teilen montiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für familie tobler ist der us rock die
letzte station auf ihrer großen reise
[Musik]
die 36-jährige mutter emma lässt es sich
nicht nehmen mit ihren männern auf die
zukunft anzustoßen
schon bald beginnt für die familie der
alltag im kleinen städtchen charlton
rolf dobler muss sein geschäft
vorantreiben und seine söhne werden
ihren ersten schultag an wo man wo man
könne mache da war für mich schlimm für
mich stimmt zu
werden wichtig wenn die ganze familie
sich nicht wohl fühlen als im moment
alles so gut klappt das ja also ich
hoffe es nicht so viele besucher
gekommen ich mich dann schlecht wenn ich
meine gastfamilie in panik aber wenn man
selbst jemand machen
[Musik]
und schlank
wenn wir ständig auf ihn
[Musik]
so wie der ayers rock in australien ist
cape coral mit seinen vielen kanälen ein
beliebtes ziel für florida touristen
dennis und clyde tänzer haben ein
ferienhaus gekauft dass sie vermieten
wollen um geld zu verdienen weil sie von
diesen einnahmen allein nicht leben
können
überlegen sie noch einen kleinen block
zu kaufen und ihren lebensunterhalt voll
mit mieteinnahmen zu bestreiten
dieses haus hat 130 tausend dollar
gekostet
[Musik]
die küche ist etwas in die jahre
gekommen dafür besticht das ferienhaus
mit einem luxus den dancers bei ihrem
wohnhaus nicht haben ja
[Musik]
es scheint als könne dennis tänzer das
neue leben noch nicht so genießen wie
ihr mann während er sich vergnügt
grübelt sie darüber nach wie man die
veraltete der küchenzeile aufpeppen
könnte um das selbst
[Musik]
auch interessant langsam langsam aber
sicher nicht da hier
da hier ist sie rufen wir hier es gibt
sie wirklich ob die sogenannten palma
chance sind eine begehrte delikatesse
die schönen exemplare kann der bieler
förster für viel geld an einen händler
verkaufen
ja das ist schöner zum beruf für die
hier schon mehr qualität
was geht was geht es schon aus witten
wird jährlich gesunderhaltung ihrer
natur nach bringen
diese weise mit witz machen oder bio
oder sie bleibt unbestritten als er ihm
eine das ist phänomenal
[Musik]
daniela ist nervös heute ist ein
wichtiger tag die seniorenresidenz wird
eingesegnet
ein buddhistischer mönch weiters
geisterhaus 1
denn ohne die hilfe der guten geister
geht nichts in thailand dass man das
hört genau nun ab juni bünde betriebene
und darum haben wir jetzt drei minuten
details glauben fest daran dass in den
häuschen die guten geister ihrer
vorfahren wohnen und so glück bringen
passiert im fall hammer käufer der
bauarbeiter und den dialog seit jahren
welt das geistliche und montiert und der
geist wird noch offen
auf dem brot laut arbeit darauf dass du
da das natürlich überglücklich dass clan
die nach und und zwei transall dass es
da machen will
ich glaube dass das wirkt
nach den schwierigen letzten wochen ist
lang und hansjörg eger glück zu können
denn mittlerweile sind weitere
mieterinnen in der seniorenresidenz
eingetroffen
die möglichst bald einziehen wollen
[Musik]
wenn schon nicht die bungalows so ist
jetzt wenigstens dass geister häuschen
bezugsbereit
[Musik]
familie tobler ist zurück in shelton ein
unwetter hat den zaun zum nachbarhaus
umgerissen
erfreulicher ist die begrüßung ihrer
nachbarin
[Musik]
hey hey um ihren flügeln könnte
ihr haus haben sie vor der großen reise
nur noch kurz eingerichtet wirklich
gewohnt haben sie hier noch nicht die
familie muss sich zuerst ein leben und
sich an ihre neuen haustiere gewinnen
[Musik]
ganz schön ich vor allem mit dem strich
sie um diesen zehn giftiger als wir uns
gegen das tornetz war ein idealer zeige
dass ich wirklich giftig wenn es keine
gifte die wochenshow und die einzige
sonntag ich habe wohl sitzen nicht
unbedingt skupin deine helmand seine
qualen und gestört wenn es einfach sie
lauten passieren
ich liebe mich sowieso oder solchen idee
jetzt andrea hammer erschlagen oder so
etwas unsanft das sowieso immer dabei
[Musik]
kley tänzer war in der schweiz beruflich
voll eingespannt
hier in florida hat er viel mehr zeit
für seine familie und er fühlt sich wohl
wieder her immer dagegen wurden im kopf
ich wünschte die ferienzentren
ferienhäuser also mit jetzt noch nie im
strandweg sie mitbringen darf space
pilatus bezüglich der dank ausbruch der
politik jetzt wohl für filme hier
eigentlich wieder her immer
weil sie in ihrem haus noch keine
waschmaschine haben muss dennis tänzer
in den waschsalon
hier ist alles neu für sie
[Musik]
da schlug
seattle
ist es ein zeichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die linke habe geld
nicht nur der waschsalon ist ungewohnt
auch wenn dennis tänzer probiert sich in
ihrer neuen heimat einzuleben vermisst
sie die schweiz und dass sich das wirft
natürlich
alles neu jetzt leider springt denn das
gab nicht auf
oh nein
die neue technik sie
[Musik]
braucht
in kanada ist der auto unterstand fertig
gebaut
und wer sich über die enormen ausmaße
wundert kennt hermann schönbächler nicht
mit 8000 flüchtlinge
hermann schönbächler geschäfte mit einem
befreundeten händler im nahegelegenen
terrors diese verkauft die kostbaren
pein mushrooms weiter mit japan mit dem
verkauf von pilzen hat hermann
schönbächler in dieser saison bereits
über 2500 franken verdient
und auch nächste woche bedient er sich
aus seinem paradies
der förster scheut keinen aufwand um für
christinas geburtstagsfest eine
delikatesse auf den tisch zu zaubern
in thailand kommt es zum eklat die
ersten mieterinnen reisen bereits wieder
ab
ich habe für mich
in australien wird es für die länder
ernst nach den langen ferien hat er
seinen ersten schultag in einer sprache
die er kaum versteht
und in florida beginnt auch dennis
tänzer ihre neue heimat zu genießen
die familie macht einen ausflug in die
everglades
[Musik]
wichtige siege
trauma
sie wollen
[Musik]